e merci d'ailleurs on a une question du
go qui nous dit comment elle manière là
qu'on peut t'il être crédible en ne
créant que 10000 postes dans la police
est ce que votre avis la réponse elle
est avant tout une réponse de
d'effectifs et de budget non ça fait
partie ça vaut pour la sécurité comme ça
vaut pour d'autres missions de l'état et
en particulier l'école on a bien vu que
le nombre de postes n'étaient pas un
indicateur fiable ensuite de la réussite
d'une politique dont il ya vraiment un
changement de logiciel a opéré là dessus
pour tout le monde y compris pour les
forces de l'ordre
après c'est de la redistribution des
fonctions à l'intérieur des effectifs de
sécurité va vous étiez peut-être oui on
a évidemment un mouvement qui doit
s'opérer avec ses classiques 1 mais
moins de personnes dans les bureaux plus
de personnes sur le terrain on doit
avoir une utilisation plus massive de
tout ce que peut nous apporter
aujourd'hui la technologie
on a aussi on en a parlé ça commençait à
devenir peut-être une forme de
privatisation de certaines fonctions ça
va être extrêmement sensible aussi des
demandes on a parlé pour les radars sur
les autoroutes
et quand même et toujours de très très
très restreint à l'intérieur des
missions de défense de sécurité
aujourd'hui on sera pas effectivement m
v
et on en a beaucoup parlé au moment des
attentats mais la question du
renseignement a livré royal ré adapter
leur enseignement et qui n'est pas
fonction du nombre de personnes combien
voilà il ajouté